[Music]
you know what you know
is i've made tons of decisions along the
way that hurt me financially but
protected my community
the garyvee audio experience
vaynernation how are you i am fired up
for a very special podcast
one of the great ogs of on-chain
ethereum
nft land has joined me
this gentleman is admired by the people
i admire
uh which uh makes it super fun we're
gonna really jam here for a little bit
this is going to be a very very good
podcast i know it because i know i can
feel my own energy
and because what's been going on in the
in the vayner communities like obviously
nfts has
been encompassing our 2021 so many of
you are learning so many of you are
prospering
you're being educated you're watching
out for scams
your cynicism for a lot of you has
thought out
you're learning we have a balanced
conversation of this
one of the great things that happened to
me uh in the process of be
friends was being introduced by jimmy uh
to jimmy excuse me uh
and his company nft 42 which i've
invested in
they were the backbone in my partnership
on
getting uh v friends to where it was and
how well it went and uh
and what i want to talk about is just
nfts og stories
the state of the union i'm really going
to interview
jimmy here for my own enjoyment and
you're going to be able to listen in but
uh
jim why don't you uh take the floor for
two minutes give everybody your name
your your company and a little bit about
yourself
sure yeah hey gary thanks so much for
having me on here uh i've been really
looking forward to this you and i have
had you know some conversations
throughout the months about nfts but i
think you know being able to capture
this knowledge and share it with your
audience is
incredibly important and a lot of has
gone on in the last couple weeks since
we caught up so we can talk about the
current market and
some some fun plans um i'm jimmy with
the one j1
mmy dot eth you can find me on twitter
and other places
as gary said uh founded nft42 and also
nameless
avastars and tokensmart these are all
companies in the metaverse
and uh had the honor to work with gary
on befriends
and we've also as a result of that done
some really great
other things such as uh sotheby's uh
national digital auction
we got to work with sir tim berners-lee
on
his nft and a variety of other
really cool projects i myself started in
the space as a collector i bought my
first crypto kitty december 5th 2017
and a couple months later after i had
done my 50 hours of research
a little late i realized that these
things weren't as good as i thought they
were
and that's what really kicked off my
passion towards building
nfts and putting them on chain and
that's really how
i ended up meeting gary and having the
incredible opportunity to work with him
is that
you know something i just could not let
go and a conviction i could not let go
of led me
down this path that i'm on now so thank
you so much for having me gary jimmy i
have a luxury of like
becoming your friend and and knowing
something so
before you got before december 5th 17
you buy the cryptokitty
you were in tech right yes uh
well i was in tech i was i was actually
in the woods when i found
ethereum which is why i found
cryptokitties but i was in
uh i worked for google um and i had
come to work for google by starting my
own uh business that provided google's
uh gmail and other services to
businesses
and as a result of that business had the
opportunity to work alongside google
and then google actually um had me
working with them on strategic projects
where you know
i was a good fit um so yeah i had been
in the technical what about even before
that before you started that company
like like as a high school kid or a
college kid right right
were you a techie yeah i was the
computer guy
at the settlement company that i worked
at you know i was the guy who helped set
up the
very simple network and set up
everybody's emails but i was a
settlement coordinator for real estate
and before that it was a real estate
agent and before that i was a loan
officer
um but i was always the the technology
actually was introduced to me computers
i was introduced to at a very young age
uh we had an intellivision which i'm
sure you remember
snafu on in television still my favorite
video game of all time oh my god that's
incredible so i remember the football
game
and i remember pong and the paddles uh
that was in her
basement 1982 i think my grandmother how
old
how old are you jimmy i'm 43 i was born
in 78.
so and in 1982 or 83 my grandmother
bought my
father his first computer it was a dos
computer with
you know black screen and green green
ink or green uh text
and that was uh you know the very
beginning
you know i always was there and
interested in the computers my father
was always interested in computers i
used to go to video arcades
so for me it's always been like
computers video games
technology in that sense it was always
fun um
and because it was fun uh it was never
daunting to learn and it was always
exciting i built my first
uh computer when i was 18 years old i
think i built my first gaming pc
um and then that's what led me to be
able to build my ethereum mining rig i
had the confidence
to go out and buy six video cards and i
figured if i could make a computer with
one video card i could probably figure
out how to make one that connected six
and sure enough that's what allowed me
to buy my first uh cryptokitty
what gave you the re you you know i
remember my eureka moment because it was
five minutes ago
you know eric aaron battalion big shout
out you know he made me buy ethereum
years ago and i'd always kept an eye on
it but
i really got crazy and you know i met
rohan in the summer and
be a top shot caught my attention but
then it got real serious in december
january
um what what did you buy any top shots
hold on did you buy it
you know what i didn't rohm and i had
i'm a big fan of
obviously he's tying this all together
for him but he's listening
rohan was behind um crypto kitties as
well which led
he had his own you know journey which
led him to building his own blockchain
not on ethereum with flow
and nba top shot you know i've never
really talked to rohm about that to me
that is a
ambitious and smart business decision if
you can pull it off you keep
many more of the economics but he
learned a lot things you know
man it really it was funny we met in
june or july i fell in love with it
and him we talked a ton through the
summer and the fall
i was just trying to navigate
vaynermedia through covet
so i you know i had some crazy combos
with rohan where i was gonna get like
the one of one lebron
like i was like really in it right but i
never but then it exploded
and i was so passive that i didn't think
i could come and do monday morning
quarterback i felt it was inappropriate
for me to reach out to rohan and say
hey you know those deals that we were
kind of trying to verbalize
i'd like to like strike on them i kind
of never went there because i thought it
wasn't fair because i dragged my feet
you know because i was busy i just
couldn't get and so that kind of sucked
and i was sad i was like [ __ ] i was so
on it but i missed the boat i literally
owned zero top shot
what was interesting was it's not
because i don't believe in it
it got so hot and expensive but i also
thought that there was a supply and
demand vulnerability
which i think has played out yeah i'm
i'm probably gonna buy the majority of
my top shot
in the next two years not
first of all they were too much like
sports cards unlike punks
meaning if terry rozier wasn't going to
be good there was like
with with a crypto kitty at avastar a v
friend
you're playing in the disney wwf
game with topshop you're playing in
sports so even if it's the first
nft basketball thing if the player is
not good that's just like sports cards
first card rookie card not good
so i wanted to wait like i'm very hot on
the melo and lebron
top shot i just um i want to wait
nonetheless
um i [ __ ] remember oh
yeah you're eureka
why in the woods what happened had you
heard about bitcoin
had you heard about blockchain or was
this all fresh yeah no this
i actually did i knew i knew quite a bit
about blockchain and ethereum so i lived
in san francisco you know when i was
doing all that stuff
with google i was very aware of the
technology i remember mount gox getting
hacked and it was like 600
bitcoin that dropped down to like 400 or
450
i even mined some bitcoin in a browser
in like 2011 or something i never like
did anything with it it just stayed in
there and then when i went back to
i thought it was coinbase actually.com
that was the site i don't think it was
but i could never find the site where i
did it and i never
counted on it so i was aware of it i
just thought it wasn't
i wasn't a believer in the technology
and what really really really caught
my attention was when i was walking in
the woods and a guy is telling me
i'm walking on the appalachian trail
i've been on the trail for like two
months um
and this guy's like yeah i'm making
money while i'm walking down the trail
and i said how are you doing that he
said oh i'm mining bitcoin
and i i said wow that's crazy and i
remember asking him like how much is a
bitcoin worth these days and
i don't remember the price in you know
may 2017
but my sense is it was like something
like 4 000
or 6 000 whatever it was it was like 10
times more
yeah blew your face off you're like wait
a minute how long have i been in the
[ __ ] woods
yes like and like really like i had been
looking i
left my business in the in the middle of
2013 and decided i didn't want to work
at google anymore in the beginning of
2014
and for three years i didn't know what i
was going to do next i was lost i
couldn't
figure it out because i wanted it is
that why is that why you went into the
trail like
yes i just like lost myself and i needed
to find myself and needed to figure out
what was next i needed
so you like literally actually pulled
off the thing that people want to do
in the most literal form like people go
off the grid
to find themselves but usually it's
within their own thoughts
you went off the grid and actually
stumbled on some [ __ ] dude
that became the scene of you being where
you are today
it's incredible right like yeah you go
into the woods you go
find the answers and you know it's like
some metaphorical thing
like like very hard to be make a
tangible thing but i actually did find
the answers in the woods and
really my goal was to walk all the way
up to
maine right i wanted to go the two
thousand two hundred plus miles
um i made it 750 miles and i feel like i
failed but really
you know that journey that walk that 750
mile walk was the beginning of my
journey into nfts
so i didn't fail turns out
so that was then you just like flat out
were like yes
yeah so it was a couple weeks later i
mean i was already i was ready
i was done by then like i made it to
virginia symbolically i was home because
that's where i was born
or where i grew up rather and so i
was just done i got off the trail i did
get distracted by a beautiful woman for
a couple months but not too long after
that i remembered
that i was here to do a thing and i set
up my mining rigs before uh
in november of 2017 and that's when i
got started and then
you know the month later that's the
cryptokitties were right there and ready
for me and i didn't know at the time
obviously that i was going to get into
nfts
i was into the altcoins i was doing all
the trading but
similarly to that epiphany that like
machines can work for me and wow this is
a real thing
like when i saw kid the cryptokitties
and nfts and i understood you could take
two crypto kitties and make a new one to
me that was like you can create new
value
out of these digital assets and there
was something extremely powerful
yet again about that it was like
blockchain's powerful nfts are really
powerful and that's like
just it was this force multiplier for me
and it it's one of those things where
you know
i have um i have attention deficit
disorder and one of the benefits of that
is that i can really focus in on
something and
and well i don't have a choice sometimes
i just have to think about something
over and over and over again and nfts
happens to be the thing that i think
about every day when i wake up
so you know in the absence of of direct
thought i think about nfts my mind
wanders towards nfts
so i get to benefit from that um in in
that you know i'm always thinking about
them
and that's been the case for the last
three and a half years
so uh that's my superpower
joey for everybody who's listening so
you get crazy about nfts
the 2017 2018 29 you know that whole
thing like
there was a real lull there it was real
quiet in 18 and 19.
tell us all us youngsters including me
people that are trying to put history
together
17 there's a moment right kitties
there's a little bit of a moment
here you know punks like it was out
there do you remember
do you remember you remember punks oh
yeah i mean
i couldn't justify paying like
zero five each for a punk like when i
could breed a kitty for point zero zero
eight eight because i could breed like
five or six kitties but i i
there was like why was i gonna buy a
punk i can't breed it like
oh yeah i mean i totally remember all of
us do that were around and didn't buy
punks
and then started to slowly all of us
slowly but surely capitulated and
ended up buying some punks um you have
to understand first of all before we get
to the
the crypto winner and the nft winner
like crypto kitties
like i dogged it a little bit the
beginning saying it wasn't what i
thought it was the art's not on the
blockchain i mean
cryptokitties is still a better nft than
most nfts
it just was an experiment that
apparently
the mass market has not responded to in
the in a positive way in the long run no
one like
you know all of me and our og friends we
all have a lot of crypto kitties like a
lot and
you know a lot of our ideals and
everything else were born out of the
complexity of
uh breeding cats and the um the
um the random not the randomness but the
statistical outcomes that you could
achieve and like all of the
deep genetics and everything else there
was a like it's a complicated
[ __ ] complicated but fun game and a lot
of really smart people gravitated
towards that
um and then things like punks and uh
were out there and already there but it
wasn't super exciting to anybody at the
time
uh in particular because it wasn't you
weren't couldn't do anything with them
and it wasn't really
there wasn't really open sea didn't
exist
and you know you we did all of our
market stuff on the crypto kitty site
directly
um like v friends where you bought
everything there but now like they had
the second market there and they had all
of the things directly on the site
and only over time in you know the
middle of near the end of 2017 beginning
of 2018
maybe people started to use opencause
there are some other nfts out there
um and then super rare came on the scene
and all this but
cryptokitties came out it was really hot
until about
maybe march or april and then we were
really in a crypto winner by then
april 2018 and then from there on it was
the die hards that were sticking in
there and just breeding cats
and hanging out every day talking about
the future of nfts
um that led into 2019
still in crypto winner but larva labs
did
auto glyphs and released that and that
was a big pinnacle moment for me
and giving me the confidence to go out
and build an on-chain project in
avistars
but we're still in crypto winner i mean
uh axes exist
they you know i remember when they had
worked their way up to 500 users that
was like a milestone that they had 500
daily active users and
and you like know everybody in the space
at this point right because it's so
small
that everyone's and was discord the
choice or did people hang out
it was actually it was cryptokitties
discord in particular
like it was like cryptokitty's discord
was the place and then accidents where
everyone
where everyone hung out yes it was like
what you did
yeah there was punk's discord right that
existed but
it was a small community yeah smaller
just even more og than it was
right yeah um but yes it existed it was
there but it was
curious here cards were not discovered
yet
no i don't even know what curio cards
are to be honest with you
yeah maybe that's something that's
happened the last couple weeks that was
rediscovered you know what i'm talking
about curio though the first
jimmy you know what i'm talking about
the curio cards the ones that the apple
the one
the the 1175 tokens the the one that um
are you serious that this is now
officially the first project before
punks
are you so head down the last four
months on your [ __ ] i'm i'm pumped with
you right now
i love the focus yeah yeah i saw it
mentioned earlier today and i was like
man what's that
should i know dude i i
i bought them like a month ago i knew
about it even earlier
it's the first project it was before
punks oh
sick dude yeah they like it's that's
what's so beautiful about the chain
it's like you can look back it's all on
the record right absolutely a hundred
percent i'm with you on that that's
incredible i'll have to check it out man
so joey so you're so so 18 and 19 are
real
dog days but you are you just
did like let's just shoot this shot
2018-19 or dog days do you believe
in those days you're in that place where
you knew that it would look like this at
some point maybe you didn't know it was
gonna be summer 2021
but whether it was 2021 whether it was
2023
whether it was 2027 in the dog days of
18 and 19
you just have that kind of blind
conviction about nfts
uh i wouldn't call it blind conviction i
would call it some like
really uh um some deep gut
trusting my guts instinct uh i would say
that the conviction
came in and my decision to go all in
came in when i in
uh may of 2019 when i decided to build
avistars i sold my house
um i borrowed money from my mom and i
put everything i had
the rest of what i had into making that
a reality
so that was the that was the moment
where i
i went all in and i didn't know i did
not think and none of us thought that we
would be having this conversation in
2021 none of us right it happened way
too fast right
yeah we thought like 2023 2024
that we would be at the point we're at
now and that in the long run
i mean in the long run yes i think this
technology is
like so disruptive and so groundbreaking
um i believed that
for since really you know cryptokitties
you know february 2017. i think we all
had that feeling that this could be
really really really important and
significant
and that's why we thought cryptokitties
would be
the the main thing like we all like we
all thought
cryptokitties being the first erc 721
they literally created the standard
would be it but there's way too many of
them
like in recollect there's way too many
cryptokitties right now um they're
they're not good personal profile
pictures no one wants to put a cat as
their profile picture for
you know cats on the internet was cool
when they released it in 2017 but
you know they're not like no one's going
to do it these days just doesn't work
um i'd rather have an eighth cats versus
apes who knows why but
um and then you know really
as beautiful as the collection is as
much as i love the kitties um
you know they made a lot of promises
about what they were gonna do
and then didn't do [ __ ] and i still
haven't for three years afterwards so
um you know it's proof that you know the
community matters and the engagement
matters and those road maps
do matter like people do price in the
road map
but when you don't like actually deliver
on what you say you're supposed to do or
anything like that
or when your lead developer lead
person says the game starts when the
kitty clock ends which is like the gen
zeroes
and then nothing happens after that like
you lose the loyalty of your community
so you have to do it if you're an entity
project
you have to do what you're gonna you
have to like if you're gonna hype
the project you have to like deliver on
the hype otherwise like your shit's
gonna die
let's let's jump to the hype so when did
you know
[ __ ] was changing so 1819
is the winter 20 is when you start
seeing the thawing out right
yeah but you know well listen top shot
coming from december
to january like that's why but but jimmy
when i look at
punks you know because it's what's
beautiful about the blockchain and what
people
are starting to realize about me i think
i think v friends at nft
kind of was a coming out party for me
because it's been a long time
since i did the social thing and so
people have only known me in one way
when i was doing real homework what was
clear to me was
there was a group of people that started
to really bubble up in march of 2020
clearly something happened in march
april of 2020
with punks it started to bubble back up
yeah well i think what happened in part
is
just that a year had gone by since
autoglyphs were out
um do you think colby had something to
do with it
people had time because if you look at
it
so what's beautiful about what i did why
i'm bringing this up
is i just look at the sales i see that
in march
something started brewing again remember
if i need to get your radar i'm trying
to remember i mean some
usually it was it's usually some other
event
where some external money somehow finds
its way into nfts
and then when that happens the people in
the community notice the new
money in the space and then everybody
starts to consolidate around that of
course of course
of course right i'm trying to remember
what happened in that time frame you're
absolutely right
like it wasn't you know right up until
top shot it was it was 2020 that things
started to pick up again
uh i remember autoglyphs were uh doing
really well because i had 30 i
now only have nine but i sold on the way
up i sell on the way up i hold on the
way down
so i only sell when the markets are in
gold now it's completely out of control
yeah absolutely it's just nuts but but
really i mean i think so
what you what i think you saw there and
then like i'm sure there was some
compelling event that caused that to
start to run up
but we had been in the space for a
couple years
and well one i think pranksy maybe did a
big deal where he bought like 400 of
them or something like that and then
started to sell them because pranksy
provides liquidity
to markets at the bottom of the market
which really needed to pick things up
but people started to consolidate around
punks and things because
the value it was it was starting the
conversation around store of value in
nfts and how punks were a store of value
because like cryptokitties are so many
of them um axes had gotten the narrative
out there that there was also too many
cryptokitties and
was controlling their supply so you
start to get these narratives around
that
you have a fixed number of nfts and
punks like that
wasn't the way to do it initially like
you
didn't have this cap 10 000 supply but
that because that was really like a
crypto punk's
thing that they did and now that's been
what's caught on
um so having that that's that store of
value there and i think it was just the
network effect of
uh more and more people discovering then
that crypto punx was actually like the
real deal and that that was going to be
potentially the nft store of value that
narrative i think really caught on in a
big way
um and then as soon as uh
top shot like popped up like so a lot of
us bought into top shot in that
june 2020 time frame that's one of the
reasons i was asking you if you did get
in because
man i mean i remember i spent like 35 or
40 thousand dollars
on uh top shot series one packs like i
was buying you know a ton of packs and
you know a lot of us nate alex myself
um were like kind of regretting how much
we had spent we thought we had spent too
much and it was kind of silly
um other than it was crazy other nfts
were doing fine but then yeah it was you
know
december into january of 2018. why why
and so
you guys were comfy what did you guys
think about it being on flow
did you guys think that that was you
know and again
they're you know these are people behind
crypto kitties and there's a little bit
of like
you know i guess with some of the
disappointment of some of the stuff that
you talked about just earlier
there was still a lot of love for the
ogenesis still is
like like yeah we love dapper we love
rowan yeah
you know still love cryptocurrencies but
it makes sense yeah and and like we
believe in what they do
right like they do know how to market
the [ __ ] out of their products
and get the the network effect so did
you sell a lot of your top shot at the
height
i i still have like 1700 series one i
think
i'm still like the 41st best account
like on
ranks ranked account but yeah i mean
this car i'm sitting in right now i
purchased entirely
with cash paid for it completely from
top shots
so um yeah i mean i probably sold over a
million dollars worth of top shots in
january february
so then what happened like when when um
you know top shot starts popping off in
the fall and winter
yeah what's the next big moment
in like okay this is taking another step
honestly i think it was the friends gary
i think it was v friends like you know
top shot was like in full swing and then
it started to lull
um and then you actually went into full
because we talked and you were going to
do this project and
you know you made the very wise and
tough decision
that you were going to introduce your
community to nft's the og way you were
going to bring them in
and teach them how to use ethereum and
metamask and
you know while everybody including
nameless my
my company is aiming towards making this
as easy and frequent frictionless as
possible letting people pay with credit
cards in the long run and everything
else
you said that you know you wanted to do
this sooner than later and you
understood
that the technology was actually more
robust at the web 3 layer than at the
credit card payment layer and everything
else
and so you started educating your users
you decided to go out there and teach
people who never
learned about nfts or ethereum or a
metamask wallet
these are daunting things to explain to
people and uh
you went out and taught them and you
have 140 000 people
plus your you had 140 000 people in you
know april may time frame in your
discord
like you have more now i'm sure uh and
you had over 4 000 new
wallets purchase your nfts on that
launch
bringing 4 000 new nft owners for a
premium nfts into the space um was a big
watershed moment that like really
taught a lot of people about nfts it
proved to the community
that we weren't just the same small
group of people like seeing those
numbers i think kygani actually
purchased did some analysis
on twitter and said you know here's the
crossover between different nft projects
and owners and
you know vfr stands alone and this is
like a
powerful [ __ ] thing like you have
over 4 000
users um and typically a project's gonna
have anywhere from you know a thousand
to four thousand people you're at that
top end right you topped out on that and
they were all new people i remember on
launch day
you know one of the things i was doing
on the first week during the sale was
i was providing support for the users
whose yeah transactions got stuck and
this is not an
easy thing when your transaction gets
stuck you know enough ass and
all i was impressed that like i probably
helped probably two dozen people get
their transactions unstuck and make that
first initial purchase
um and uh they all got it done like they
all were able to get
i had to explain to them we had to go
through it but they all got it done and
i was really impressed
how intelligent these users were because
i've helped i was a moderator in
cryptokitties discord as a moderator and
top shot discord
um i've got my own discords with like
avistars and everything else like we've
helped
i've helped a lot of users and uh it was
always
hard to get through to people and help
but your your
community listened and was excited i
couldn't believe it like how excited
they were too
like purchasing these nfts like they
were just so excited every may so i mean
your community is amazing
so i think that was a really big moment
for
nfts as v friends um it showed everybody
the power
of these things when you combine it with
a brand
and somebody such as yourself to bring
it to bear what's amazing about that
week in that general area
is we were supposed to launch on the
fifth we launched the 12th as you know
intimately you were there in those
meetings you had
me and cubans and me and cuban and um
chamath showing up on cnbc starting to
say the words nft
yep i remember uh actually i actually
think and we
i know that you just forgot i forgot now
i can remember what actually was the
next moment in our timeline was the
people
situation oh yeah absolutely yeah so
yeah people going you have punks
getting really crazy in january because
that's what i was buying
you had people you have me chamath and
cuban
on cnbc uttering the words nft i
remember i said
flamingo and maybe bitsky and something
else and like
people are like twitter was like i
cannot believe those words were set on
cnbc
yep um and you're in flamingo now right
i am in flamingo flamingo explain to
everybody what a dao is
distributed autonomous organization
d-a-o is a dao
uh and what that is is it is a
it's a club that um there's different
forms of it the one flamingo a
for-profit
uh basically organization uh where
you're less than a hundred members it's
a delaware llc
and the way it works is uh collectively
uh up to a hundred of us uh decide and
vote
and invest a community fund
into both infrastructure in this case
nft and metaverse infrastructure and
directly into nft assets themselves
so it's basically um a metaverse version
of a club that is
very real and can have very
real assets and you can have an impact
on i don't i don't know how to explain
any clear you know i think it's great
yeah it's a it's a decentralized
investment vehicle
yeah at a vc firm like my fund
like i make the decision in in a dow
the things that they're gonna buy is
done by the group yep
and not everybody votes all the time but
enough people vote you reach a threshold
and then things happen and
it's really great because it gives me
exposure to things i wouldn't normally
pay attention to or invest in either
so jim jimmy what um okay so
and then you're about to mention people
did people
i actually think i actually would argue
people nifty gateway
was a big part of all this as well very
much i would say
people hit the globe because 69 million
broke everyone's face
yes yes and made from page news yeah
everywhere in the world so i would say
nba top shot people the cuban me
chamat cnbc thing was a little blip
computer
i would assume so but you know he's got
so many big things going on he might
have got sidetracked
yep you know i was incredibly close
to buying kitties in 2017 and if i did
my whole entire trajectory would have
been different because then i would have
gotten
i don't know what i would have done wow
by the way what if you actually were in
the space though with us for like the
last three years and like
i'm kind of quiet about it because it
was like i don't i don't think i would
have i don't know how to be quiet i
would have been loud and it might have
changed
it's true it could have come a lot
sooner right i mean
then what's even more fun for me is
the week that we were going to launch
this tiny project that nobody knew was
brewing
board api club comes out and [ __ ] i
mean i literally have one of the most
successful projects
that's ever been launched board ape
comes out and launches up in my opinion
i mean look at the floor right now it's
a more successful project
you know you know like in economics
right now at the cost that people got in
you are one of those people
you know like i commend them so much now
secretly of course i think be friends is
going to be bigger than punks
to nba topshop and board api because
that's who i am
and i'm playing for 40 years and i know
what i'm going to do
but that also i mean talk about an
amazing time in the history of nfts
that comes out as well and then you get
the pranksies and the beanies and the g
money some of these
call it influencers in the space you
like there's a lot going on so
what are you feeling like in march april
may like it's
you're like what the [ __ ] just happened
uh i mean i think that describes it
pretty accurately for me
you know it was like apes was like the
big moment like i had
a big pop off with nba you know i still
have a good collection
uh i made a good amount of money in the
beginning of the year
wow how great are nfts but then board
apes like seeing that pop off
and then how many board apes did you
make how many did you mint yeah yeah so
i made
i minted 420 nice and memetastic how
many
how many how many how much were they
point zero eighty so i spent about
twenty six to thirty eight
or so like i think roughly um i did it
all within the course of a couple hours
i went from
someone tweeted about it and i was like
yeah these look okay but they're not on
chain because i'm all about like i want
the art
no they're on ipfs they're they're like
you know
they might be putting some stuff there
but yeah no i mean it's basically on
ipfs
there's no like metadata on chain
it was a good project but like most
projects have not innovated
too far board apes included board apes
had really fresh art though i looked at
it i was like wow
these actually just look really great
and there's it is 10
000 it was their own custom contract
they didn't do it on like an open c
storefront or something so they put an
effort
and uh yeah there's i bought four like i
bought about a hundred
and then i looked and i was like oh i
thought i got the ones i wanted and then
i saw someone had a gold ape and i was
like oh no i need gold fur
so like i went back and started buying
more and then i told pranksy
he was awake by then and i was like hey
man like i posted it in one of my groups
that we're in together and i was like
hey
anybody want to like check these out and
frankie was like oh wow these actually
look pretty cool i'm going to go in
and then he tweeted about it he was
buying him at the same time
and everybody started buying them just
everybody like this
as we're filming this it is on the verge
of hitting 10
8th floor it's nine nine right now
kenny's what for what uh
yeah holy cow yeah just exploded
that's crazy so yeah i mean that was and
then
so gary though i want to i want to say
like i gave out probably about 100 of
these things
i know you did i did you gave way to
people you gave you gave me five that's
how i have that
yep i gave them away to people because i
was like this is a cool project this is
going to do well the reason i do that
and i do that
a lot i give away a lot because people
say
like i'm basically hacking people's
minds i am
planting the virus directly the nft as
deeply as it can be placed when i give
someone something that i know is going
to go up in value
and that they will see the value of it
like i give it to them
and then they get start getting offers
on it from open c and they start getting
offers and they're like
of course holy [ __ ] like race is
incredible
and i can't say that and i also think i
also think you care about the macro
space it's the reason i got so excited
about world of women
right the reason i like world of women
currently and it's doing really well and
i gave it a real push and
you know i think i only i think i have
60 or 80. right i don't remember how
many times i hit the 20 max
mint right i haven't you know i did go
buy goddesses which is kind of the top
one in that game
outside of the one you know they did
something interesting they they did
certain tokens to get a percentage of
the rake oh that's very cool
so but the reason i like that one is i
just thought it would
bring more new people into it yep it's a
you know it's a very early tech there's
a lot of bro
energy in you know nfts just a lot of
males right a lot of white male like and
i was like you know what this is good
for the space
i want to i love the art i like fame
lady for the same reason like i like
i want different type it's why i bought
justin's photography
this is photography yeah you know so for
me it's like
i want to help i mean this this thing
i'm doing on saturdays now where i'm
like if your project
failed please share a link and then i
pick one i buy one and i
share it and then the artist's life is
different it's [ __ ] fun amazing yes
this is exactly so you're
you know you and i uh you know are
taking a similar path here right we're
trying to evangelize the overall tech
the macro
of it all we want to spread the love you
have you have the great advantage of
being a true og
everyone respects you when i came in i
mean look let's go
spay the spade the friends not supported
by the og community even though i was
part of the community for four or five
months
i was like like some of the and people
that i've had nice relationships with
you know like ultimately people thought
it was a conference token
the art wasn't good they really [ __ ]
up
and the fomo is real now and i'm
enjoying it yeah no absolutely you came
in and you made like
you made the friends collection the way
you wanted to make it and what you saw
was
the og community saying we don't really
think you should have made it this way
and they were wrong right they
and i have a lot of empathy for the og
community like they still think like a
lot of
i first of all my sitting now is in a
very different place i'm so grateful and
i wanted to earn
the og community's respect because i
respect the og community it didn't hurt
my feelings that people didn't
support it i understood why they
weren't sure if the second it was over
you know what really caught me off guard
jimmy
is that and you know this the go tokens
that gary originally owned
i was surprised in that first three you
know three days where i was like oh [ __ ]
they're not gonna support it i was
surprised that nobody said
if gary's doing a rug pull and a pump
and dump and a quick cash grab
the [ __ ] is he keeping eleven percent of
all the inventory for
yeah well i'm so fascinated by that
it's funny because you must have been an
interesting spot
danny danny an og punk guy really
supported but like
you must have had some funny one-on-one
discord text conversations because you
obviously
knew me at this point we've been so nice
so i'm biased one right because i
support i helped you build this project
so like people knew that like i was for
the project
i personally purchased uh i think i
purchased 12 to 14 v
friends um and i bought a lot of those
at the top of the duck show auction
because i actually thought it was going
to sell out
because i i mean i'm about it gary i'll
tell you right now and you know
and you know this i am firm on this to
everybody
if the metamask bug wasn't there and
because people saw eighty thousand
dollars in gas fees
if we didn't have that bug the whole
thing would have been different
i mean it was a it was a couple tough
hours there because because for four
hours
because it was an hour and a half we
were down and then two and a half more
hours with the bug
and by then everybody said wait a minute
why am i gonna pay top because nobody
was like everybody was [ __ ] up
yep yep had i had i got an auction not
dutch auction it would have went the
other way but i wanted to protect p
you know what you know is i've made tons
of decisions along the way
that hurt me financially but protected
my community
yes and the fact that that you decided
then after that issue happened
that and you realized that you weren't
going to get the immediate sell out at
the top of the dutch that you wanted
you actually shifted 180 and you're like
okay
we're going to deliver as much value to
the community as possible and we're
going to highlight
when we hit the floor i also did
something else
i made i knew we're gonna hit the floor
and i decided i would never
publicly talk about it i was only gonna
talk about it in the discord
so that my most hardcore fan do you know
how i feel right now
i have a bunch of people who barely
could have
who didn't have deep pockets who were
able to buy a 45
at 0.5 right now they're at six they've
12x their money
yep now that's not fully true because
ether was a little high during that time
so still
next or eth which you could play out
like
i'm getting a text every day a dm and a
discord message every day that i
completely changed people's lives
and not only that this is why they know
about nfts
they bought cool cats they bought you
know some uh
board ape they they my community has
crushed
at least of this second world of women
like this is like
really hard oh yeah absolutely like be
friends that's what you did you created
wealth
for your entire community and that
wealth has i haven't even started
dude not only have i not only started i
want to say though by the way there were
some ogs
that like haven't like probably been
able to like tell you
but that have supported you and what
you're doing from the very start and
you said you brought up gift goat and
that was the one where they're like
gift goat should be one of the best
because
he is going to be continuously
delivering that there was a ton of og's
that supported me
like many i've talked to many i'm pumped
a lot more didn't
and this is why i love the ogs and a big
percentage of them
either privately which i incredibly
appreciate but the super ones the 5 to
15 that have
publicly come out and said i missed it i
was wrong yeah
that's just that's very nice of them yep
absolutely
i love the og i lived this with web 2.0
anil dash
jason kotke andy bio like like
when i came into that those og bloggers
i like re i still hold them up on a
pedestal even though the garyvee thing
really took off and that's what's gonna
happen here too
no matter how i think i will be the
[ __ ] guy when it's
all said and done i'm with you on this
game but
you and danny and and
and and pranks and many many many justin
like so many people and g money like
they'll always be in a different
pedestal for me because they were
[ __ ] there
yep yep i know i know it
so uh we're gonna go a little bit more
but we also have a massive
if you've been listening this long and i
didn't want i was gonna do it up front
but i'm like [ __ ] it
i want easter eggs to go to the people
that really [ __ ] with us
we have a major surprise at the end of
this podcast
uh we'll get to that in a minute as a
matter of fact we have not talked
because we're so busy
i don't even know where we're sending
them for this major surprise so i'll
probably have to
record that later i'll do that at the ps
at the end of this podcast you'll see
what we mean in a minute we'll announce
it
then we'll work on putting this together
this week and then dustin
i know you're behind right now listening
i'll add that post
production which we never do but i have
to add it to send people somewhere
for this massive surprise but i'm not
done yet we'll get to that in a minute
to me now what you know what are the
what are the exciting things and what
are the watch outs because
what i will tell you is the demand is
growing new wallets are joining every
day
but the supply is going to outpace it
the amount of ten thousand pfp
avas you know avatar like prop
projects that are coming out are coming
out 10 a day
15 a day yeah
yeah i think you've been preaching the
right uh gospel here for the last
four months um in in saying that you
know
most of this stuff is not going to be
worth anything in a few years
um you know there are going to be high
value projects and high
blue chip assets let me go to the crypto
slam we're not going to pick on anyone
because
that's not appropriate but i'm going to
go to crypto slam let me give an example
i'm very i want actually i want to go
the other way i want to give gaps to
stoner cats
meal and ash to put themselves out there
of course no
punks comics you know by the way donor
cats has caught a lot of flack from
emojis
right i know but i want to say like i
have been
i know maria very well as one of the
people involved with the project and i
respect her a lot and she's consulted
with me for months and months and months
on this
yeah in a very unofficial capacity and
i believe in that project in the long
term just like i believe in v
friends they are doing this for the
right reasons they're messaging for some
reason to not break through
um but they are doing a disruptive model
with nfts
yeah and uh i think what they're doing
nxps will fully take over all
crowdfunding
yes and they're doing this with studio
model people
i love it people are like oh somebody's
gonna do a stoner cat thing if they
wanted why are they saying that the
studios won't make this the studios
wouldn't make this and they wanted to
the studio
99 of things you talked about filmmakers
are about to love nfts once again i mean
why the hell
wouldn't uh a distributed community want
to embrace something where they get to
decide content that's made instead of
because ash and emil are famous i mean
just who cares if they're famous they're
cool as [ __ ] they're in nfts
listen i'm with you anyway nonetheless
i'm just gonna bounce around a little
bit
no no it's okay gutter cat gang great
project wicked cranium's got big love
for that bulls on the block i got love
for them
um this this the the bogu i don't know
how they pronounced that
that's gotten really hot this week royal
society of players
really interesting game these are some
of the people in the top things
uh go gutter rats uh top dog beach clubs
got a little something going on
voxey's uh you know cyber kongs has got
a little something going on like
so there's all these projects right
[ __ ] man like i know for fact not
because i know anything about these
projects by the way
it's just supply and demand consumer
behavior a lot of these won't
be at any price in you know
23 months uh going back to crypto slam
we're gonna go way down to the
hundreds let's just look at a couple
that maybe had some noise
in the past you know a couple months
like um you know
my [ __ ] pickle right remember that
little they've been oh yeah oh yeah
right
that they've done a hundred dollars in
184 dollars in secondary last 24 hours
right who's gonna buy the pickles guys
look at look at look at look at chubbies
right i was super hot about it was the
first thing i got excited about i love
the art
little did i know the art was stolen
that [ __ ] got hurt right
deadheads was a project i like the art
hasn't really taken off
i mean you know like it's you know like
a lot of these things
can't potentially sustain right right
and there has to be
like people interested in even buying
them at all otherwise they're literally
worthless if there's no market
if there's no buyers for these things
then they're not actually
there because there's gonna be
consolidation they'll inevitably be a
little bit of a winter around
don't forget in two days you probably i
know you saw this stat
open c in two days to 91 million yep and
open
uh correct me i know it's in the 90s 95
million
95 million and in the year 2020 which oh
by the way was eight months ago for the
entire year
of 2020 they did 21 or 25 million yep
yeah so that means and that means over
the weekend
in two days open c did
4x 5 almost 4.5 x
4x what they did the year before the
year before
over two days so let there be no
confusion we are in a [ __ ]
tsunami right now obviously bull run
bubble right now like this is as bullish
as it gets
you should not be buying nfts right now
you should be selling nfts right now
while you should be buying because
here's what's interesting it's like a
funny thing
i'm with you the problem is there's a
project right now
that is actually the one in five years
and is
and and that becomes the game do you
know do you understand what's your
intuition
it's like anything it's investing it's
real estate it's stock
it's it's just real but it's but when i
made a video earlier today
but it's [ __ ] fun in a different way
yes
like so so look so i don't know if this
is gonna be perfect and this was a
thought i had at like two in the morning
when i'm half asleep
but like what i think we are doing right
now is
we collectively the nft space we're that
group of kids in the movie the goonies
and we actually like found the [ __ ]
treasure
like we actually found the treasure
breaking news a very wealthy very
prominent person
just texted me 7 23
it's now 7 25. two minutes ago i just
saw it pop up i'm sorry to interrupt you
but
we're really trying to educate people
what's brewing literally i'm gonna just
read it
uh i'm not gonna say who it is know
anyone trying to move a zombie
alien or ape oh [ __ ]
this is just what's going [ __ ] i'm
finished your thought i'm sorry go ahead
no i think we're the goonies like i
think we've actually like found the
treasure we saved the town
but like the town is actually like our
imagination
growing up and like the promise that
there was going to be cooler [ __ ] that
came
after like the 80s and the 90s and the
early 2000s and like
you know just the ideas that were born
in those times around technology and
where the space was going and i think
like nfts are actually like
the solution to a lot of those things
that connect
the fun that we've been having in video
games and in sci-fi
and all that to actual like a form of
reality
and so like i just like think that like
it's the funnest
time to be alive in technology because
we get to like we just get to make it
all up in a good way now like all of us
have grown up around like these
video games and like these gamification
mechanics and all these things
and now like there's serious money
coming in behind all this fun
so like we're actually gonna continue to
be able to get a lot of you know
you know let me give you a comp you know
it was a lot of fun and then serious
money came along
just not in the last hundred years what
is it
it's called sports yes perfect yes
like let me this is what i'm good at
analogies here you go friends
sports used to not be a business
baseball teams and football teams made
no money they were unorganized
this happened this was a humanity there
was a time where there was no major
league baseball there was a time
the nfl is a new business like
people don't get it sports this trillion
dollar thing that we all accept is a
trillion dollar thing you like this one
jimmy right dude i just got the chills
man
it's a good one right i just got the
[ __ ] chills we just happened to be
around when this nft thing happened
and it is going to gamify everything
yes yes and it disrupts everything all
right let's drop the bomb on them jimmy
i'll give you the floor what are we
doing well so you know
when i was looking at uh that chart uh
that i
referenced a couple uh like 20 minutes
ago or 30 minutes ago that this guy
kaigani made kai um it showed that like
v friends had the most unique holders in
all of the nft space
like the the best like most
like organic community created newly
created community and
so i realized that there was a really
great opportunity if like
projects could get the attention of v
friends
that they could actually flourish
because like you said the friends are
killing it right now that your community
is killing it they're able to get
involved in other projects
and i was like you know i wanted i want
to basically
find a way to get avastar's in the hands
of as many v friends holders as possible
so what we started to do was something
called project terminus
inside of avistars and that was we
started to mint out the rest of the
avatars from our own company account
um with the intention of uh allowing
uh v friends owners people who own a v
friends as of a date about two weeks ago
in the past actually
um to go in and claim one of i think
1300 uh avastars that will be available
for free if you have a v friend uh in
your
in your metamasker and your your
cryptocurrency wallet um
there's not there's not enough for
everybody yep this is first come first
serve
so friends what you're hearing right now
is one of the great og projects
created by one of the great ogs of the
space i think i'm
i'm just going to make it public i'm
going to go and buy some more of these
out of stars on the open market because
i think
you're seeing it happen moon cats is
going through it right now like
pre-2019 projects are gonna have their
day
they may not all be punks but they're
gonna have their day and i think avatar
is the first on chain
like fully on chain personal profile
picture project they're there forever
i think you're going to have a day jimmy
and so the fact that we are going to
allow the vayner community
the v friends community actually
specifically if you owned the be friend
by a proper
prior day because they had a mint they
had to execute it at a snapshot of the
wallets
yeah so uh when i do my post it's fair
that way it's fair yeah
no you did it buy one right now uh
first 1300 people are gonna be able to
grab a free avastar
which i think is very very very gracious
of you thank you it gives a free asset
and by the way i was telling jimmy that
you know i've got to think brewing with
befriends
where i've got a whole concept for v
friends that if you own a b
friend we're gonna help new projects
kind of launch we're gonna i'm gonna do
that url in the post production too
because we kind of just
decided to record this right now we're
gonna do before but
uh at the end of this there'll be a
pause and i'll give you the details of
where to go
both on v friends to if you're a project
making a new project and you want to
give away
555 coins to befriends people in your
launches you'll have a form
and then there'll be a second place to
go uh to for the 1300 of you that own a
beef friend
to get an avastar i'll do that in
post-production what an incredible gift
from jimmy not only to reward 1300 v
friends owners with an avistar
but it became the micro seed of a new
macro strategy for me with me friends
i kind of that's what i do i hear
something and then i build on it
i'm going to help emerging projects i'm
going to do two nice
i'm going to sit in the middle i'm going
to help emerging projects get
distribution from a great community
so that 555 tokens that are going to get
into people
and then i'm going to help every v
friend holder in the world continue to
amass things
could you imagine the amount of i'm
looking to do this often so this is just
the beginning of new innovations and
that's what we're here for dude holding
a v
friend like uh it sounds like that is
the play right now yeah it becomes an
asset builder right
every new project and god forbid one of
those new projects is board api club
there's gonna be people who are gonna
get a free token airdropped
that will eventually be worth more than
their befriend because
that's just what's gonna happen
eventually one of them's gonna hit what
about when someone figures out that they
can just like
create a collection of 555 and nothing
else and give them to your community for
free
and then create value really thinking
anyway brother i love you
love you too gary everything you're
doing i i'm i'm about it
because he's a big fan and i'm so
honored to be a part of this dude
nft42.com if you want to figure out how
to do a project
he's building a massive we didn't even
get into that maybe another time right
you know why i think you might become a
very unusual
person in my ecosystem you might become
a regular of the podcast
actually if you think jimmy should be a
regular podcast hit me up on twitter i
want to see those comments
thank you everybody listening uh and now
i will give you the information of the
exciting things we ended with
all right everybody here's the ps if
you're just listening to the epic
podcast with jimmy
if you want to know about the avastar's
giveaway to be friends it's garyvee.com
avastar's popped up right here i'm sure
in post-production and if you want to
know
about if you're launching your own nft
project and you want to give 555 tokens
out
to the fee friends community go to
garyvee.com
plp the plp
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you